Tom chicken hat their security minister
I have a bit of breaking news to
bringing our particularly important and
sobering given the politics that we're
discussing here in Westminster this
evening security sources have told Sky
news that a police officer has been shot
in Omar in County Tyrone that's in
Northern Ireland now the officer has
been taken to hospital because of their
injuries well let's talk a little bit
more about that breaking news uh shall
we and also some of the wider political
story we're covering now we're joined by
our senior Island correspondent David
Blevins
um firstly just bring us the latest that
you know about the shooting our sources
within the Police Service of Northern
Ireland are telling us that one of their
officers has been shot and wounded in an
incident on Kelly clarker Road in Omar
County Tyrone a place many people will
remember because it was where dissident
Republicans carried out the worst single
atrocity of the troubles the bombing the
claimed the lives of 29 people and
unborn twins now there is no indication
as to what the the circumstances were at
this stage but it certainly would appear
to Bear the Hallmarks of a dissident
Republican shooting they have previously
claimed the lives of two members of the
Police Service of Northern Ireland uh
Constable Stephen Carroll and Constable
Ronan care and along with two prison
officers and Two Soldiers so I suppose
it's a vivid reminder for us as the
politics of the protocol is debated in
Westminster that Northern Ireland 25
years after the Good Friday agreement is
still a divided society and the place
where the pace is very fragile